now brady this is the bit that really is
going to do your head
which i'm going to enjoy
i'm going to show you how
light can be polarized by sheets of
polaroid this is a sheet of polaroid
it's a polyvinyl alcohol with iodine
thrown in it so in here i'm not sure
which way around it is there are long
molecules
which are stretched out and they conduct
along this direction but they don't
conduct that way so that's what your
polaroid sunglasses are made of stuff
like this which is built into it so it
reduces the glare for example off the
road when you're driving along so i put
a sheet of polaroid on top of this
overhead projector which produces light
and i put another sheet on top polarized
the same way and they absorb a bit of
light for each direction but if i turn
this top one round
so that it is actually perpendicular to
that original direction you can see that
you can kill off most of the light so
there's some turning backwards
and that's gone all the way around
and now i'm going back again and you can
see that it disappears
this is an off cut a bit chopped off
from the bottom of this to make it a
square and i can put it on top of these
two let me square them up and you can't
see it at all i can put it underneath
these two and you still can't see it but
if i now slide it in between you can see
i'm rolling this up in the bottom corner
and sliding it in between
you see you can see it if i turn it
around this way it disappears if i turn
it round to 45 degrees you can see
something quite strong and then turn it
around a bit more and it disappears it's
magic now you see it
no you don't
now you see it
now you don't
amazing what's going on well i i find
this absolutely fascinating i couldn't
believe this was going to work first but
i'll show you another set of equipment
over here
which is some microwaves this is a
microwave generator and it will generate
waves which are polarized in one
particular direction
and here is a receiver which will
receive them
this wave has a wavelength which is
three centimeters now three centimeters
is about yay long whereas the light wave
is sixty thousand times smaller so if i
set up travelling waves waves coming out
of here and ending up over here not
being reflected
then it'll be a bit simpler so i'll
detect this by turning this on and
getting a very nice big signal
now i pick up a sheet of polaroid this
is my sheet of polaroid it's just long
conducting wires the same as we're in
those uh sheets of polaroid but you
couldn't see them there so now i put it
in this way around
and you see that you don't get any
signal and i turn it around
and i get a huge signal on the meter at
the back so there it is
nothing gets through and i turn it round
slowly
and you suddenly see the signal appear
and when it's perpendicular i hit a
really big signal
on this screen over there what's
happening here
is that this
is sending out waves which are
oscillating with an electric field that
goes up and down in this direction
and as the electric field hits this
conducting wire
it induces a current in here and because
of the resistance of the wire this
causes the electromagnetic wave to be
absorbed and heat to occur in the wire
so it gets totally absorbed by the wire
if i turn it round this way
well now the electric field causes a
little bit of current to go across there
but then it hits the other side of the
wire and it doesn't dissipate any energy
just gets stored there as a capacitance
so this does not absorb nearly as much
energy and so i get quite a large signal
and then i turn it round
there and i get virtually nothing
now i want to turn this around to show
you that they're completely polarized
oppositely so if i have that vertically
this is now giving an electromagnetic
wave which is oscillating vertically
this is now detecting only those waves
which are going horizontally it's just
like those two sheets of polaroid there
so i have a wave which is coming out and
oscillating this way and this one is not
tuned to detect it at all so i get no
signal
now i've put the sheet of polaroid in
and there's nothing there if i turn it
to 45 degrees i get a huge signal going
through if i now turn it around to
perpendicular i get nothing so i'll
start off vertical there's nothing there
i turn it round i get a lovely big fat
signal coming
about 45 degrees
and then when it goes further around
it decays away to zero
so something is happening if i put this
in at 45 degrees
i mean able to get
waves which are oscillating this way to
go through here and be detected by
something which is detecting waves that
way i'm changing this signal which is
oscillating this way to one that's
oscillating that way otherwise nothing
would go through how have you done it
well i haven't done it it's this sheet
of polaroid that's done it
so if i imagine this is a wave which is
coming out and has a vertical
polarization like this i can think of
that as partly this angle this side of
the set square plus that one so as i put
it in at this angle
if i think of this as being vertically
polarized up and down
it's partly this and partly that so as i
put that in there the bit which is
running this way along this wire is
killed off and the bit which is running
that way
is now allowed to continue
so i have a state which is oscillating
this way now and this thing has managed
to turn the plane of polarization of
this wave from
vertical to this direction
now when that this wave travels along
this way
part of that is horizontal and part of
that is vertical and the horizontal part
goes in
so i have a wave i measure it it changes
the state of the system from being
vertically polarized
vertically polarized to one polarized in
this direction once i've done that this
state can be detected by that that's the
interpretation of this
whole experiment
and that's the classical interpretation
in terms of electromagnetic waves now
brady this is the bit that really is
going to do your head
which i'm going to enjoy for the next
few minutes out of this apparatus comes
one photon
it is a photon which is
oscillating this way the chances of the
photon going through here are 50 50 can
either be going this way or that way and
if i do it 45 degrees they're equal
equally probable then you get to this
detector and now it's coming out with
that polarization the chance of going
this way are 50 50. so i'm going to only
get a quarter of the signal going
through if this really works and that's
the explanation why the signal's gone
down but notice now as this photon comes
through i have to talk about
probabilities of what goes on it is not
deterministic
and if you go through the mathematics
you'll find that these states which i
would like to represent using a ket
which is a triangle like this and you
put the symbol in as a triangle
that kept state
changes from one to the other and i in
here in between i have a mixture of
two different states and it's a mixture
of these two states that allows me to
interpret this experiment
so it's much harder for poor old brazil
to understand because somehow quantum
mechanics is biting him on the back side
here and he really doesn't like me to
talk about mathematics at all but
without that and without the idea of
splitting this into two different states
added together i have no explanation for
what's going on so get your head around
that brady i'll just edit that bit out
how do sunglasses work then sunglasses
work
well i haven't got them but i used to
have clip-on polaroids and somehow if
you're looking at light which is
reflected off the road for example the
light
that's polarized in this direction is
taken away so you find that you have
transverse polarization only and if you
get rid of that you then reduce the
glare off the roads completely and so
you don't get any nasty reflection off
the roads or if you have a river and
you're looking at the surface of a still
river or pond
it will get rid of the glare off the
pond and you can actually see into the
pond and see all the fishes below the
other reason they work is because it
seems to attract all the girls if you're
really cool unlike me